mein schöner Sommerlook ganz einfach für
euch erklärt zuerst bin ich mir die
Haare zu einer schönen Frisur zusammen
als nächstes nehme ich mir meinen
Concealer den benutze ich nämlich auch
als Base für den Lidschatten einfach ein
bisschen was aufs Augenlid auftupfen mit
den Fingern verreiben und dann mit dem
Puder fixieren mit dem Augenbrauenstift
käme ich mir jetzt erstmal die
Augenbrauen durch und verdichte sie da
wo ich einfach noch ein bisschen was
benötige den Matten hellen Lidschatten
gesetzlich unter die Augenbraue um die
Augenbraue optisch zu heben und aufs
bewegliche Lied kommt ein richtig
schöner matter Rose Ton perfekt für den
Sommer so ein bisschen roseglo kommt
auch noch auf die Augen und zwar innen
an die Innenwinkel des Auges den
Augenbrauenstift könnt ihr übrigens auch
benutzen statt einem Eyeliner und könnt
außen an den außenwinkeln einfach den
Wimpernkranz ein bisschen verdichten